it rides against the snow
red raw and vicious too many mouths too
many limbs twitching and dripping
once it looked a lot like you but now
it's something different entirely
if ever it escapes its bounds it'll
rebuild the whole world and its image it
is known and feared by everyone with
sufficient clearance at the scp
foundation and for good reason it'll
infect anyone and anything and a death
sentence is preferable to infection it
is a disease that thinks the crawling
corruption the flesh that hates or if
you fear its true name too much to speak
it and find comfort in the
categorization and clinical eyes of the
scp foundation scp-610
scp-610 is a contagious skin disease
transmitted by direct contact anyone
infected with it suffers a horrific
mutation turning them into fleshy
inhuman monstrosities these infected
creatures will attack and infect anyone
nearby that isn't also carrying
scp-610 this also happens to be the
flesh described and adored by those
following the twisted religion of
sarkicism a violent cult and group of
interests that worships flesh corruption
and disease and as the foundation
operatives tasked with observing groups
of interests now
sarkicism is a sect that directly
opposes the machine revering church of
the broken god and to understand the
events of the tale known to the scp
foundation as aftermath the beginning
that leads to its brutal and
world-changing end one must first
understand the endless conflict between
these two groups the church of the
broken god is a religion that the scp
foundation has had a number of
encounters with over the years members
of the church share in the belief that
biological flesh-based life is an
inherently wrong and evil abomination
they worship mechanization the process
of making organic bodies something more
mechanical in nature according to the
beliefs of the church two gods yadavath
and meccan created humanity together
yaldabath was the god of flesh and
animal instinct granting humans bodies
meanwhile the god of machine and
intellect mccain blessed man with the
power of free thought as humankind
developed machines yaldabaoth became
enraged that they were ignorant of the
instincts she had given them and
endeavored to destroy the creations of
man as the church's legend goes mccain
acted as humanity's savior and tried
desperately to stop yaldabath the god of
machines shattered himself transforming
his body into a number of pieces to form
a cage for his fellow god fragments of
mccain rained down on planet earth now
the church of the broken god believes it
is their duty to recover these missing
parts there could potentially be
hundreds of pieces needed to rebuild
meccan and a number of these happen to
be catalogued as cps that the foundation
is either aware of or has in containment
our story begins not with the
long-awaited return of mccain the broken
god instead it begins with a man a
foundation foot soldier named roderick
freeman this is the story of aftermath
in 2003 at the age of 17 roderick's
ambition was to join the u.s navy and
become a member of the renowned navy
seals after enlisting and completing
three years of rigorous training they
achieved his ambition only to climb even
further to high teen never could have
foreseen in 2017 roderick now a seal was
recruited by the scp foundation after
his skills and aptitude caught the
attention of their embedded recruiters
he joined one of the foundation's mtfs
or mobile task forces elite units that
are often sent in to directly deal with
anomalous threats specifically freeman
became a member of mtf new 7 also known
by the code name hammer down the task
force you call in when literally nothing
else can do the job to bring hammer down
onto the scene for anything less than a
potential xk is like swatting a house
fly with a nuclear warhead sir roderick
a gun host soldier boy if there ever was
one would fit right in but what does
this mobile task force have to do with
all that talk about the church of the
broken god and the flesh that hates well
after an incident that broke out in the
irkutska area in russia they were the
ones responsible for cleaning up the
mess left behind according to roderick's
account a robot the size of a small
building was spotted in this area during
december 2018. this 30-foot tall robot
had apparently come to wipe out a
rapidly spreading disease as you can
probably guess
that disease was
scp-610 the flesh that hates at first
the global cult coalition had fired on
the robot launching a volley of
ballistic missiles in an attempt to take
it down
this move failed the robot protecting
itself so that not even a piece of
shrapnel could hit it it barely seemed
phased by the attack and went about
destroying remnants of scp-610 as it
found them any infected with the flesh
were obliterated and when its job was
done the robot simply left perhaps this
wasn't quite the grandiose return from
mccain that the church of the broken god
had envisioned for their deity but it
was nevertheless the long-awaited return
they got what had happened was that the
scp foundation called a lifted veil
scenario the truth was now out the world
would soon be aware of the existence of
anomalies afterwards freeman and the
rest of hammerdown recovered a series of
tablets that had been left behind by
mccain each of them bore a simple
repeated phrase in a variety of language
just the words i will return a short
time later riots began to spark across
the world it was a disaster too big for
even the foundation to cover up
according to roderick multiple anomalous
groups such as the serpent's hand and
the chaos insurgency had gone public in
mexico the insurgency became involved in
illegal businesses that gave the cartels
an anomalous run for their ill-gotten
money while members of the serpent's
hand used the air of tension to incite
riots in short everything was a mess and
this eventually escalated to a
full-scale civil war in mexico in 2021
during the build-up to this around 2019
there was unrest around the world and
mobile task forces like hammerdown were
being deployed to train alongside
various public safety organizations all
in the hopes of getting the world
prepared for the storm gathering all
around them the insurgency and the hand
had revealed the truth about anomalies
to the world and so the foundation's
mtfs were aiding law enforcement special
forces and the like readying them to
defend against the anomalous in 2022 the
foundation finally decided to intervene
in the situation down in mexico where
the chaos insurgency and the serpent's
hand had been causing disruption
roderick freeman was one of those sent
to juarez coming face to face with
former cartel members turned lackeys for
the insurgency the chaos insurgency had
been fighting with the foundation for
decades and knew all their tactics
combine that with the ferocity and
brutality of a lifelong cartel member
and even the toughest soldier is in for
a fight as it turns out the fight wasn't
even the worst part for our dedicated
little soldier while attempting to
transport a person of interest across
the texas-mexico border roderick and his
squad were ambushed by a sniper during
the attack freeman received a wound to
his spine that left him paralyzed from
the hip down however even though the
foundation didn't like to admit it the
church of the broken god was actually
highly skilled in surgery after all they
worshipped mechanization and would often
augment themselves using technology or
to use roderick's own words if you
wanted an iphone in your skull in 2009
they could have pulled it off if you
wanted to be able to turn the lights on
and off in your home by blinking they
had an upgrade for that if you lost the
use of your legs because of a sniper on
a rooftop and juarez they had you
covered thanks to members of the church
there had been a new technological
revolution since the lifting of the veil
by 2024 devices that felt like they were
20 years more advanced than technology
should have been were now commonly
available so that's how roderick freeman
was able to walk again however the scp
foundation refused to let him return to
duty forcing him into an administrative
role frustrated he applied for a job as
a containment specialist meanwhile the
state of the world was constantly
changing with the scp foundation handing
over safe anomalies to world governments
new divisions and departments were being
formed to deal with the containment of
scps there was even an anomaly
registration program that allowed people
to call 9-1-1 to report dangerous or
life-threatening anomalies anyone
exhibiting anomalous abilities could now
find doctors or therapists rather than
being carted off to a containment cell
in short the foundation's days were
numbered however this was not as idyllic
as it sounds according to roderick this
should have been a chance for the civil
rights of anomalous people to be
respected something that the serpent's
hand had been campaigning for since
their modern inception instead it meant
that anyone with anomalous traits
perceived to be dangerous was arrested
as threats to national security things
were nowhere near as restrictive as
under the foundation the safer anomalies
could even have visits from family but
there was one boy thomas whom roderick
had to look after remarking that he
wasn't old enough to be kept in a
containment setting little did roderick
know the tests that were being run on
thomas were keeping tabs on him somehow
the boy was able to use anomalous
abilities to watch where roderick was at
all times the scp foundation was finally
disbanded in 2027
with the containment of anomalies
becoming the responsibility of the
global coalition council this
organization had long been the official
sanctioned counterpart to the more off
the books foundation despite their more
violent methods but now the goc was
making their work known to the public
but with the foundation gone roderick
was out of work picking up odd jobs over
the next six years there was widespread
criticism of the scp foundation and its
dubious methods the dark things they'd
done to keep anomalies contained
civilians killed entire populations
given memory wiping drugs to forget
about scps the horrific treatment of
d-class personnel a document containing
details about these practices and more
was leaked causing an outcry the scp
foundation's brutal methods were
declared to be crimes against humanity
alongside this paranoia about anomalies
was spreading governments were
encouraging their citizens to report
paranormal happenings and people with
anomalous traits were being registered
and arrested in roderick's account he
says when people don't understand
something one of two things will happen
they will try to understand it so they
can use it for their own ends or and
this is far more likely they will grow
afraid of it and try to destroy it so it
was when humanity rediscovered anomalies
former foundation employees were
declared public enemy number one with
anomalous persons at close second when
former members of the foundation began
to find themselves on trial by the
united nations the public began
executing any ex-foundation personnel
they could find head first local police
or even the national guard would
intervene but some eventually started
actively helping the vigilante mobs
there was nowhere for roderick to hide
the fbi even used the unusual incidence
unit to track down the foundation's
remaining members some had even been
hired by the uiu to bring in their
former co-workers and for anyone who
knows how utterly useless the unusual
incidents unit are to be brought in for
execution by them is a truly humiliating
death unsure who to trust roderick
turned to agent leonard wells a man
whose life he had once saved meeting at
a diner in wisconsin leonard agreed to
smuggle roderick to russia for five
thousand dollars getting him safely out
of the fbi's jurisdiction freeman agreed
and was then led to an suv with three
other men that he didn't recognize
according to leonard they were just
there to help smuggle roderick the five
of them drove to an isolated stretch of
road only to stop something was terribly
wrong leonard told roderick to exit the
car claiming that they would need to
switch vehicles as the suv drove off
leonard handed roderick a flashlight and
told him to signal a nearby grove of
trees and then
according to a report roderick x freeman
was wanted by the u.s government for the
actions he was involved in during his
time at the scp foundation he was
believed to have been responsible for
human rights violations and was picked
up by agents of the fbi's unusual
incidents unit the report claimed that
roderick engaged the uiu agents with a
small firearm although he had reached
out to agent leonard wells for help
whether he was executed or tried to run
away roderick freeman was shot and
killed but that was far from the worst
part about his death dying is bad enough
but witnessing death especially at a
young age is something that can have a
long lasting effect but who was there to
see what happened or rather who could
see without being there thomas the young
anomalous boy roderick had been assigned
to had seen the whole thing the world
had changed undeniably it has been said
that the foundation dies in the dark so
that we can live in the light but when
the same light was turned on the
foundation itself it seemed that they
couldn't survive under its scrutiny
either whether the world is better or
worse without them is something only you
can decide now go check out scp-5000y
the full story compilation and the o5
council must die
scp-001 the way it ends or a borough
cycle for more terrifying tales from
another timeline